unfortunately the academic system that
exists sucks most people that you see
have not done the thing that they are
teaching what they do they are spouting
things that they have heard and just
regurgitating them and so they do not
understand
why
it is that way they are saying it is
that way but they lack the details they
lack the nuance of having done it and
being able to troubleshoot it because
they didn't actually build the thing
they observed it being built and then
relayed it to their audience and most
people haven't done it you have to
do the thing well like training your
back well do the sales well
in order for your skill to improve and
the way to do that is a lot of times by
having somebody who is much better than
you teach you how to do it and so we
have to pay or learn in other ways and i
think you can either go to a company and
learn those skills specific knowledge
from doing it or you can do it yourself
right like i like the idea of getting
earning while you learn right go to a
company get paid to learn right i think
it's like one of the best things in the
entire world